but first tonight after almost 200 years
the Democrats were a political party
with conventional political goals that's
no longer true Democratic Party is now a
religious cult with all that implies
dissent has been banned anyone who
questions the party's leftward fringe is
denounced as a racist heretic the party
is descended into a purity spiral and
nobody is safe not even the party's own
leaders
Nancy Pelosi for example she's the most
left-wing Speaker of the House in the
history of the United States she's been
a fire-breathing liberal for longer than
I don't know Alexandria Kazuya Cortes
has been alive but none of that has been
enough to save her Kazu Cortes and a
tiny group of house freshmen demand
explicit socialism in this country right
now they want to open the borders empty
the prisons and take over the entire US
economy in the name of fighting climate
change now Pelosi may agree with these
goals but she has contempt for their
total ignorance of how laws are made
there Ignace of the democratic system
itself and closely has expressed that
contempt repeatedly in public including
here she likes to minimize the conflicts
within her caucus between the moderates
and the progressives you have these
wings AOC and her group on one side side
side people so for saying things like
that Pelosi tonight is facing a revolt
from within the Democratic Party she's
being denounced guess what they're
calling her you know a racist
here's congresswoman Rasheeda Talib
explaining that Pelosi is oppressing
people of color more people like us
people of color have been missing in the
chamber because most of us and Jana
Presley says it more beautifully people
that are closest to the pain need to be
at the table making these decisions
guess what we know what it feels like to
be dehumanized we know what it feels
like to be brown and black in this
country what would you say to Nancy
Pelosi what would you say directly to
Nancy Pelosi
uplift the women especially the women of
color within your caucus that are out
there because I'll tell you more people
like us more people like me that come
out to vote we win all of us win
give us power because of our skin color
that's the argument to leave
making many make that argument Acacio
Cortez made the very same case during
her Democratic primary campaign last
year by definition it is a racist pitch
it's every bit as repugnant as a white
candidate making the same appeal and
many Democrats did make that appeal that
racial appeal under Jim Crow vote for me
because of my race it's disgusting but
it's everywhere now and Democrats
applauded it yesterday for example
former Obama spokesman Brian Fallon
tweed that Ocasio Cortez and her faction
provides quote the vision and moral
center of today's Democratic Party
that's a view that is widely shared and
is bad news for people like Joe Biden
like Pelosi Biden has dedicated his
entire life to the Democratic Party as
Pelosi has Biden has dutifully moved
left with the party over the years and
hasn't complained about it
he's currently running for example on
free health care for illegal aliens but
none of it has been enough people like
Joe Biden are the past in the Democratic
Party and like so many others he's being
denounced wait for it as a racist it's
over for Joe Biden a bitter end to what
might have been a decent political
career only he seems to be unaware of
that on Saturday Biden grabbed grovelled
one last time in a doomed effort to save
himself
watch that swai I chose here in South
Carolina and chose an audience that in
fact is would be the most likely to have
been offended by anything that was said
but it's pointless it's spitting in the
wind the Democratic Party remorse is a
sign of weakness and the weaker eatin
shortly after a Biden spoke those words
Michelle Obama was asked her view of Joe
Biden now a decent person might have
said a kind word about her old friend
Joe he was the man after all helped make
her husband president and served under
him for eight years that's not what
Michelle Obama did watch if anything
you like to say about the caramel Abidin
Dustin he apologized today you've been
following that do you have any thoughts
about that
I do not okay let me ask this moving on
I've been moving on I've been doing this
rodeo far too long yeah moving on who's
like and no comments moving on no
comment
Joe Biden not worth defending he's over
just like Thomas Jefferson and Betsy
Ross and all kinds of other people who
aren't absolutely aligned with the
modern woke left the Democratic Party
demands absolute perfect fidelity at all
times anyone who fails to measure up is
finished forever now that attitude is an
effective way to terrify weak people and
keep public figures in line but the
question like Toria Lee is will it work
on the country normal Americans know
they're not racist they don't think
their neighbors and friends are racist
either they don't care about that they
care about their jobs their safety their
families their country for years they've
watched in despair as both major parties
drifted away from those concerns they
took a chance electing Donald Trump
because he seemed willing to put the
basics first
well they react him is the question well
Democrats continue act like this
absolutely they will